seize mille mètres carrés implantée à
saint quentin en yvelines bmw france va
bientôt changer de locaux un nouveau
siège pour le constructeur allemand à
quelques mètres de l'ancien dans le
quartier du pas du lac à montigny le
bretonneux qui va regrouper sur un seul
site trois entités du groupe bonjour
vincent salim en mauges aux longues
oreilles canal et président du
directoire de bmw france la livraison de
ce nouveau siège est prévue pour bientôt
alors elle est prévue pour la fin de
l'année globalement les premières
entités les deux premières entités vont
déménager au mois de janvier et bm nous
les français donc la dm2 légaux en
france la filiale commerciale va
déménager début février jusqu'à 8
février tout le monde s'installe tout le
monde sera installé à la mi-février
alors les travaux avaient débuté début
2018 ce sont 100 millions d'euros a en
tout qui ont été investis par lever
france vous parliez des entités donc bmw
france qui était déjà montini bmw
finance qui était installé en gare pas
très loin et alphabet france qui est
implantée à rueil-malmaison dans les
hauts-de-seine pourquoi réunir les trois
entités en un seul site en fait tout
simplement pour s'adapter par rapport à
l'environnement économique par rapport
aux nouvelles façons de travailler
on nous étions trois entités trois
filiales du groupe allemand installé en
france mais avec trop de silos et c'est
vrai que la distance géographique ne
facilite pas la façon d'optimiser nos de
développer les synergies et donc il
était important qu'on puisse se réunir
dans le même site c'est pour ça que le
bmw group a montré vraiment beaucoup
d'intérêt sur le marché français en
investissant beaucoup d'argent beaucoup
d'intérêt sur les yvelines parce que
c'est un site stratégique et en
réunissant l'ensemble des entités pour
qu'on puisse renforcer les synergies
tous ensemble mais rester sur le
territoire de 50 ans et munis rapportant
il ya beaucoup de constructeurs qui sont
implantés qui ont leur siège sur ce
territoire la plupart des constructeurs
sont dans l'ouest parisien et dans les
yvelines
parce que c'est assez stratégique malgré
tous ses proches des équipementiers
aussi ce qui est un élément important
et puis c'est facile d'accès et donc
quand on réunit nos concessionnaires ou
quand les cantons les fait venir sur
paris c'est aussi très bien qu'ils
puissent avoir un accès rapide et on
imagine son nouveau siège qui répondra
aux enjeux actuels se
l'environnement c'est aussi en termes de
bien-être des salariés les mettre dans
les meilleures conditions de travail
complètement c'est à la fois les mettre
dans les meilleures conditions en termes
de façon de travailler mais aussi d'
optimiser l'efficience et la
collaboration l'aspect collaboratif des
collaborateurs c'est vraiment très
important donc on est bien évidemment
sur des open space
mais on est même sur un fax au fils en
fait il y en aura pas de bureau d'abord
il ya pas de bureaux fermés mais en plus
même les bureaux physiques ne seront pas
affectés puisque chaque collaborateur
pourra s'installer où il le souhaitera
n'importe quand à partir du moment où
ils travaillent de manière vraiment
transfert transversale avec ses
collègues parce que son nouvel de
nouvelles manières aujourd'hui de
travailler
ce sont pour moi et pour nous en fait
pour l'ensemble de bmw group france ce
sont les meilleures façons de d'être
efficient et de pouvoir vraiment
travailler avec une une efficacité
totale avec l'ensemble de ses
collaborateurs au sein d'une entité est
aussi les collaborateurs d autres
entités est de développer continuer la
stratégie de bmw en france justement bmw
en 2018 en france dans l'hexagone ce
sont près de 85 mille voitures
immatriculées
quinze mille motos et scooters ce qui en
fait le premier constructeur en france
sur le marché premium la stratégie c'est
de continuer ce qu'il ya de nouveau
projet qui est alors il ya toujours de
nouveaux produits
je suis simplement rectifier un petit
celle de 85000 immatriculations il ya
quelques mini en fait il ya eu à peu
près 27 mille mini bmw group en france
et bmw ces mini et bmw motorrad vous en
avez parlé tout à l'heure et la mobilité
est en train d'évoluer
l'environnement économique et
l'environnement du secteur automobile
est en train d'évoluer
est il important de développer les
nouveaux produits c'est pour ça qu'on a
lancé la nouvelle serre est une il ya
peu de temps on a on a au mois de
septembre dont on a vraiment une
offensive produit qui est très très
forte et on développe aussi les services
donc on travaille sur la collectivité au
sein des voitures ont travaillé sur la
voiture autonome
aujourd'hui on parle plus d'assistance à
la conduite mais c'est un élément très
important
on travaille beaucoup sur la voiture
électrifiée et on travaille sur les
services partagés et aujourd'hui dans
paris vous pouvez payer votre parking
avec park now qui est une application
qui appartient bm de les groupes alors
le véhicule électrique le véhicule
propre justement en 2018 5726 voitures
produites par bmw si une augmentation de
3 % par rapport à l'année précédente
c'est de continuer dans cette voie pour
l'année 2010 9 et celle 2026 et
indispensable à fin 2010 9 en or est
immatriculée dans le monde le bmw group
cinq cent mille véhicules électrifiés en
france la bmw i3 est un vrai succès on a
lancé en octobre 2013 donc c'est une
voiture 100% électrique
on a encore fait plus de 40 % de
progression en immatriculations sur le
mois d'octobre 2000 voyez qu'il ya
beaucoup d'intérêt et on prévoit à fin
2021 d'avoir immatriculé 1 million de
véhicules électrifiés dans le monde
parce que ça fait partie des nouvelles
mobilités ça fait partie des enjeux
environnementaux aussi et il est
important que nous puissions être
présent sur l'ensemble des motorisations
y compris la motorisation électrifié
alors une question sur le lieu qui nous
accueille aujourd'hui le golf de la
boulie adversaires vous avez témoigné
devant les entrepreneurs de livres in
business club pourquoi c'était important
pourquoi avoir accepté cette invitation
parce que c'est important de pouvoir
rencontrer les décideurs les managers
d'un département qui est très important
comme le département des yvelines
et puis il ya une petite anecdote et au
golf de la boulie c'est un élément
important aussi parce que bmw très
investi dans le sport est très investi
dans le golfe
les partenaires de la fédération
française de golf qui est installée un
peu de kilomètres d'ici szavay au golf
national
on a été partenaire de la ryder cup qui
a été un événement planétaire
fantastique qui a eu lieu dans les
yvelines l'année dernière on est
partenaire de l'open de france qui a
lieu aussi au golf national et donc il
est bien de pouvoir rencontrer les
décideurs et échanger avec eux sur les
nouvelles mobilités moi aussi sur
l'environnement économique mais de façon
informelle au sein de ce club
et puis de pouvoir parler de l'avenir
aussi merci vincent saly mans et je
rappelle que vous êtes le président du
directoire de bmw france merci raisin